it's happening the Trump team is
discussing a Muslim registration system
Kris Kobach the Secretary of State for
Kansas who is believed to be a key
member of President Donald's transition
team has revealed that Donald's policy
advisors are discussing plans to
establish a registry for Muslim
immigrants in the United States this
would force immigrants from Muslim
countries to be registered in some kind
of central database now mr. kobak helped
devise tough immigration laws uh in a
number of u.s. states and claims to have
participated in regular conference calls
with trump's immigration advisers the
role has not yet been confirmed by the
transition team but there is every
indication that this is someone we can
trust on this issue the Muslim
registration would reportedly see
Muslims given some kind of ID which
would note their religion on it it's
sort of like a religious ID card and you
may not remember have known this but
there was actually a similar idea
proposed under george w bush which kris
kobach also helped to design which also
would have required thousands of Arab
and Muslim visitors in temporary US
residents to register with the state
that was abandoned in 2011 after being
criticized for unfairly targeting
immigrants from majority Muslim nations
correctly so so there are some real
questions about this Pat number one is
it even American to do this right if you
have a country founded on religious
freedom of and freedom from religion
where people are not treated differently
based on which religion if any they
adhere to if you have a system that
categorizes people by religion that is
fundamentally on American isn't it is
there any other explanation yes totally
antithetical to the United States
Constitution air First Amendment and you
have to wonder what's next are they
gonna have to wear triangles on their
shirts reminiscent of the nazi
concentration camp era the line from
having a religious ID card in your
wallet to having something on the
outside of your clothes is a pretty damn
blurry line now the second question the
practical question is would this help to
prevent terror it's not clear that it
would put aside that most terror in the
u.s. is
committed by Muslims anyway although
worldwide it is not in the United States
remember that a registration system is
not gps tracking unless they're secret
tracking devices in these cards that the
Muslims would have to carry around it's
a list of people who follow a certain
religion and the connection between that
and its usefulness in preventing terror
is very difficult to make now even
though Trump has been backing off of
some of the ridiculous campaign ideas
it's really important to remember number
one believe people when they say they
will do things until we have evidence
that they will not and every indication
now is that the registration of Muslims
in the United States is something that
president-elect Donald wants number two
do not allow any signs of normality from
the Trump transition team to convince us
that there is not a huge risk of major
unamerican actions happening in his
administration and number three we can't
just rely on institutions to save us
courts have upheld really horrible
things in the past one Republican whose
name escapes me right now actually said
you know the Muslim registration thing
is justified because remember when we
had the japanese-american internment
camps if this happens the counter
movement should be everybody should
register as Muslim all immigrants should
just say regardless of their actual
religion Pat I'm Muslim register me
please which would instantly make this
database completely bogus and and not
usable in any real way and by and large
most people reflect on the internment
camps of the japanese-americans very
shamefully was a very shameful part of
our past yeah who is going to point to
those Japanese American internment camps
as a good thing or a model for anything
that we want to do in 2016 that's insane
I it's where we are living in bizarro
world and we need to remember that this
needs to be made abundantly clear that
this is a constitutional issue right
think about it gun ownership is
protected by the Second Amendment and
any attempt to create a national gun
database is vehemently opposed by the
NRA and by many many other groups but
all of a sudden we have a registration
system for people
based on religion if you're so concerned
about the Second Amendment in this way
just look one amendment back at the
First Amendment and and you can see very
quickly why we have not only a major
major problem here in terms of
constitutionality but we also have a
major double standard and double
standards are never too far behind when
you look at ideas like this send me your
thoughts i'm on twitter at d pakman
warby parker is offering a free five day
home try-on to give you the opportunity
to check out their glasses i personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try-on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trial dot-com / TDPS I don't really like
going into glasses stores and trying on
glasses while the salesperson sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home try-on I was able to pick
five pairs that i liked put them on in
the comfort of my own home pick the one
I like the most and then Warby Parker
put my prescription lenses in there for
me a lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker
dot-com / tdps it costs nothing